les voir, vous allez être
surpris!
♪ ♪
- Si je vous parle du projet
du projet de troisième lien à
- Oui.
- Vous me dites quoi?
- Moi, je dis qu'il est temps
que ça se fasse.
- Pourquoi?
c'est pas une région.
C'est une métrop... bien, c'est
une capitale nationale, avec
une envergure internationale.
- Troisième lien.
Comme ça, avec ça dans
- Vous êtes pas très favorable.
- En tout cas... il y a rien qui
c'est économiquement rentable.
- Ça va peut-être faire plus
aller là-bas, puis moins
de trafic.
- Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
du projet de troiss zéro!
- Pourquoi pas? C'est les gens
c qui savent.
- Je penon ait besoin
d'un troisième lien à Québec.
J'irais plutôt pour le tramway.
plus tôt à leur travail.
- La planète va faire une crise
cardiaque, et nous, on est là,
troisième lien!?prends queprendt
besoin d'un troisième lien, mais
je suis pas certaine de la façon
que ça se passe en ce moment.meé
et je réfléchirais.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Moi, pour être honnête,
je pense que ça va juste créer
du trafic, mais plus loin.
- Moi, je pense que l'argent
qu'on va investir pour le
troisième lien, on devraitl'inve
climatique.
- S'il y a véritablement
un besoin, je dis pas non.
- Je trouve qu'on devrait av
plus de ponts à Montréal, puis
Québec devrait en avoir moins.
- Justement. Monsieur Legault
dit que les gens de Montréal qui
s'opposesième lien
regardent les gens de Québec
et de Lévis de haut.
Vous en pensez quoi?
- Non, non, c'est pas une
question de regard de regard de.
- Moi, j'aime pas la dissension
que Legault crée.
- Je regarde surtout pas
les gens de Lévis et de Québec
Ma belle-famille
habite à Québec.
- Je suis tanné des, des...
Montréal-Québec. Regarde,
on peut-tu vivre ensemble?- Voun
de regarder les gens de Québec
de haut?
- Non, pas du tout.
Au contraire, on les adore!
- Un message de paix, d'unité...
- C'est ça, exactement.
Vive Québec!